women love porn a new study by Anne
Summers suggests that women watch a ton
of porn and not only are they watching
it it's improving their sex lives let's
look at the results 55% of women watched
pornographic videos on their own at
least once a month
9% of these women say they watch porn
every day 76% of women favor soft porn
47% favor roleplay
alright 96% of women have watched porn
with a partner with 58% saying it
improves their sex life 40% admitted to
making their own sex tape so my first
question to you Jen is where is your sex
tape somewhere on an iPhone I'm sure
they mean iPhone hit record mean snap
you know this is a thing when they say
porn it surprises me that as many women
are watching straight up porn or
hardcore porn because just my Instagram
feed I am so inundated with borderline
explicit images all day whether it's via
selfie or someone's artistic photoshoot
or a new cool in the Instagram magazine
is popped up that's all just black and
white sexual images so I wonder what
they're considering porn because it's
kind of like you know Supreme Court like
I know it when I see it yeah some of
that I'm like that's it's porn you know
it's not see but that doesn't go to the
difference I think between the mind the
mind of a woman and a man cuz I could
look at my Instagram feed and see a lot
of things that are close to form but I
know there are no way close to there no
way Puri and interests I believe is part
of the definition does it get you hot so
how it so just will take it to the base
level first general thoughts on porn
does porn do anything for you and if it
does does it help your sex life oh yes
it does it's the right kind of porn does
it you know and it's it's stimulating
definitely and it's fun to watch with
your partner but I think too much of it
desensitize as people to human
interaction and I think unrealistic
expectations with young with young man
is it just it creates really unrealistic
maybe you like you know dude looking the
way certain performer does or doing what
they do it's like it's like I feel like
in my sex life I'm starting to autopilot
I just hit like a tape recorder like I'm
not I don't sound satisfied and how does
a guy know a woman is satisfied if she's
not making these creepy weird like
dolphin noises the whole exactly no I I
think it's a good thing I think you know
this country is way too uptight about
the sexuality in our bodies and I think
that's why we have so much porn because
we're just uptight about it so we can't
have conversations day-to-day about it
on television we can't you know people
would rather have someone walk into a
room with a machine gun and kill 50
people that show women's breasts yeah
you know so that's really shows a lot
about where our thinking is in this
country
it's generationally it's it's shifting
over generations though I think that the
younger people as you become more
desensitized to sexual images and nude
bodies and selfies and you know the girl
is a Fitz Poe on Instagram or people
taking semi naked bikini pictures and
putting on Facebook younger people are
starting to not need as much porn
straight-up I feel like when you talk to
people that are a little bit older it
was like that was how you get off
because the way you're saying because
the Americans are so uncomfortable their
bodies in sexuality you don't look like
a large porn or nothing but yeah there's
like kind of this blended line of sexual
like things that maybe will turn you on
or a little bit titillating but aren't
quite porn that it's becoming more and
more mainstream that I think actually
like hard what penetration tight porn
doesn't have to exist as much as just
seeing like graphic imagery or even semi
sensual imagery right so okay so the
people on the right would say you know
this is this is all bad and all they're
always afraid of their bodies and all
that kind of stuff but don't you think
that this as this stuff trickles up as
you see more stuff on Instagram or or
whatever it is that's allowing us to see
our bodies more that it'll be ultimately
a healthier generation of people because
I remember when I was 13 I found a box
of Playboy magazines near the post
office and like first off I was gay but
just anything anything sexual of any
nature and my friends and I we hid in
the box behind a tree
we hold in a box and like then the
things were missing from the box and you
know then the box is sticky it was a but
but you know to me like it became like
this secret thing and this shame thing
versus now it's just sort of there and
you know yes it can't totally be
controlled but it's there and it and Big
Damn whoop yeah I don't know I'm I'm 50
so I have a different I don't know what
the younger generation is I know I'm the
body Instagram and all that kind of so I
don't really know about like what's
going on right now with all of that but
but yeah I mean back in the day it was
well you know I grew up coming of age in
the 60s and 70s so it was you know there
was a lot of sex going on a lot of you
know unhealthy boundary sex going on
which is not you know any better than
anything else but there's more unhealthy
boundary imagery going on than actual
sex and that seems to be a huge product
of the Internet is instead of engaging
in all the sex instead you can get the
idea of it from the internet or think
about it or have the expectation of it
but I don't know if people are engaging
is is much freedom that's actually it
just that's an interesting point because
I would venture to say that if you asked
anyone even the most Pro porn people if
you said to them if you watch 10 percent
less porn would you be happier or not
necesary happier but would you be more
productive perhaps or you know usually
you watch porn anyway ya gotta do that
again like I think it's like anything
else it is in some ways and we have
these kind of addictive personalities
and you know sex addiction is a problem
and watching too much porn is part of
sex addiction and I you know I think you
are avoiding other parts of your
personality and other parts of your life
so but but I think this woman's study I
think this is interesting is I think it
is women connecting to their sexuality
in a way that's saying you know I want
to enjoy this time and not make this so
taboo and and there's a lot of porn
that's I mean absolutely it's treats
women horrible and depicts women
horribly I mean that's why that is the
only fear I have is that I feel like
even myself as I watch more and more
pride you start to kind of start to
change your expectations about the way
this role exactly so it's strange it's
not like it should be banned because
great give people what they want you
know people who have women need to be
making women's porn right because I
think erotica is really for women it's
much more about the relationship and the
kind of emotional connection in between
and that is titillating for women is as
much and more so than the visual of the
penetration is mostly geared towards
mangas men have been the consumers of
porn that's kind of almost teaching
women what porn is and how to receive it
yeah yet I don't know if that's what
turns me on or if that's just what's out
there it'd be interesting to see later
because it's poor yeah well you know
what I've a lot of lesbians have told me
that they really hate lesbian porn
because it's all made by men so they're
they're seeing images of women that mean
nothing to them and then they're having
sex in a way that they never thought on
this so 40% of the women surveyed said
that they've made their own sex tape so
that goes to this sort of instagraming
and snapchatting of everything again is
this ultimately freeing like we're gonna
get some of this stuff out and we won't
have you know the the scandal every
other year with the Anthony Weiner or a
Filner you know grabbing women it is
because some of this stuff is gonna be
exercised anybody my age or younger that
hasn't at least taken a photo or rolled
on their iPhone or they're on something
just taken a few seconds of video of
them doing something with a partner yeah
or take it even just pictures selfies of
themselves naked to see what they look
like and you can lose your phone and
someone could get it so as again right
right seriously well as the drummer yeah
as the generation of people finding it
more acceptable to do this kind of takes
over and becomes in power positions
it'll be less important no one will care
if people cared about Anthony Weiner
because he was just like a kind of like
sociopathically and Craig you know just
crazy with the Carlos danger and things
the story behind it was amazing and
eventually people will not care if
somebody has a picture of their dick on
a camera
no one cares that's a good thing
[Music]